hello folks I hope I have a good
connection sometimes I don't first I
wanna say that if you see me a little
skinnier I've lost 5 kilograms about 11
pounds I'm gonna crash diet and
hopefully by the end of the month I'll
go from where I started at 96 kilograms
maybe down to 85 that's my that's my
goal so and I'm doing exercise
unfortunately the pain in my back
haven't heard from it in a in a few days
at least a week so I'm happy about that
I thought it was gonna take about a
month two months three months I don't
know that's what I had heard anyways
today I'm gonna be handling some of the
fan mail in fact I had quite a bit and
so I'll be addressing fan mail then I'm
gonna open the floor up for anyone who
has questions okay and let's see put
this over here
so that I can see if anyone later on has
question anyways I'm gonna start with a
review of what I did the other day okay
and Senshi here it is talked about the
fact that homosexuality and autism are
on the rise nobody seems to question
autism as much as they do
maybe homosexuality but I guess most
people have this sense that both of them
are increasing and I'm saying that we
have to look at history especially in
regards to homosexuality and find out if
there was any increase from the old days
to what we see today and I'm saying the
first law against gays came the official
one came out in the coda basura 1100 BC
and it's just that homosexuality became
a phenomena at least as early as 3,000
years ago
meanwhile the codes of or namu
and dipp'd Ishtar as well as Hammurabi
which is the most well known of of those
and there were a couple others all these
date from 1,800 to 2,000 plus I think
2200 BC and none of them mentioned
homosexuality in any way and I do have
to clarify that a little bit the Code of
Hammurabi only mentions one instance and
that's father and son and it forbids it
obviously it penalizes it but the issue
is that to make sure everything's okay
here let me know if anybody can't hear
me or whatever okay on the comments
there anyways it was only father and son
and there's no other mention of that at
all whereas the other code specifically
stated as a separate matter first they
deal with the family issues you know you
can't see with your grandmother you
can't see with your mother that sort of
thing and then as a separate issue they
put homosexuality separate in fact you
can see the same thing in Leviticus
Leviticus first deals with family
matters
then deals with homosexuality is a
separate matter so they're separated hey
getting back here just on the review all
ancient codes punished homosexuality and
you know that's something that the gay
lobby turns around and they say well
yeah they only punish the bottom the guy
in the the guy the guy in the receiving
end and that wasn't the case obviously
the cold of a sewer makes clear the
opposite in fact that the in this case
appears to punish the top and lobby the
gay lobby obviously has to reinterpret
that and they say well they punished
that it was rape that it was not
scented sex well you know what with the
gay lobby never understood and I think a
lot of the people who write these
history books that deal with
homosexuality never understand is that
there's a lot of locker room talk as mr.
Trump would say in the old days what
happened was that in the old days people
would say just like they say today no
differently in fact you know we're gonna
screw you guys
and what does that mean what do you mean
you're gonna screw does that mean that
this team the eleven guys on this team
are gonna screw the actually have sex on
the field with other eleven guys no
obviously not it's a way of speaking
meaning that you know I'm gonna
overpower you I'm gonna be more powerful
you you're gonna be my my little slave
sex slave that's what they're saying and
there was no it was no different in the
old days it's not that they punished
only the the guy in the bottom very
under receiving yet if you saw two
homosexuals in the old days having sex
they would have had the same reaction
heterosexual has today they would have
buried the both of them alive okay there
would be no they wouldn't lay the guy in
the top off the hook and say hey you're
macho you did well no no they would have
buried him as well so you know there's a
misinterpretation of history as far as
I'm concerned you know by the gay lobby
okay continuing here all Greek men were
not homosexual or by spec's bisexual as
the gay lobby spreads today there's no
evidence that Achilles and Patroclus
Alexander have festoon were gay and I
talked about that the other day chapter
9 in the Iliad makes it clear that
Achilles and Patroclus love girls they
slept with girls and the same thing with
Alexander have fest you and in fact both
of them had wives Alexander I think had
a total of three wives for sure he had
through two of them hey no no clue
whatsoever that Alexander was gay
all room um no men were not homosexual
or bisexual as the gay lobby spreads
today the Lexx Cantina the law against
homosexuality punished homosexuality and
gay lobby sweeps it under the rug saying
nobody knew about it well you know I
think they did know about know about in
one of the procedures comes from the
same gay lobby where they analyze the
fact that people in Rome communicated
homosexuals in Rome communicated through
codes there was a subculture it was
underground they had to do it in secret
and that certainly doesn't point to the
fact that homosexuality was out in the
open the both the Greeks and especially
the Romans they had four-letter words
against homosexuals Tomatis which meant
Ganymede Ganymede turned into Roman was
katha Metis and Ganymede was Zeus's
little boy he was Zeus's Kabir
and from Greeks to Romans they had
another idea what Zeus was doing with
him especially when Hira his wife was
very jealous of her of him and spit Rhea
which was the sphincter okay that's what
the homosexual was called okay and yeah
the room was referred to it as a Greek
vise and in all ancient cultures the way
to put a man in the worst possible light
was to say that he was homosexual they
were not glorified under no
circumstances not only all laws punished
it all people spoke of them in the worst
possible light if you wanted to throw
dirt on someone best the new rulers they
use homosexuality as a propaganda tool
okay and they threw it on previous
rulers especially if they the banquet
were still popular in the case of Nero
especially lol Oh God libelous that's
the other guy that I mentioned the other
day they just threw a lot of dirt on the
guy and the people who the sources that
we use for a lot of Roman and Greek
history comes from Tacitus with Tonya's
guests Cassius Dio and
these guys were born after the subject
matters you know there was the subject
matters that they deal with the Roman
emperors especially these people came
after the the Emperor's died so there
there's no live witness all these are
hearsay old wives tales you know and
especially Suetonius I'm sorry she
cashed she was die oh he exaggerated a
lot and he came a hundred years after
the last Roman that well the the Roman
Emperor that Tacitus analyzes and quite
a bit of detail which is Nero
yeah and so Cassius Dio knows nothing
about the died above Nero except what he
got from the people like Tacitus who
wrote you know heavily about them so
Alexander Caesar Marc Anthony Nero
Hadrian ellegua ellegua la l gobble us
all were married to women so there is no
indication that any of them in fact in
the case of la la bellows he was he
married a vestal virgin which was
forbidden by Roman law that's why they
were called virgins and so he was eating
care he committed all kinds of sacrifice
because he had a different religion and
maybe it's one of the reasons they they
murdered him finally okay so where does
all this stand today if I can get this
is where we stand today we have
homosexuality is on the rise according
to me and I think the data shows it
statistics are under eyes you can
question the statistics but one thing is
for sure and that is that the growing
numbers the strength of homosexuals is
what triggered the psychological and
psychiatric associations to remove
homosexuality from the list of mental
disorders
and you can imagine that if if there
were few homosexuals in the world there
were ten homosexuals for example they
wouldn't have been able to change the
law the only reason the law was was
modified as there were so many of them
suddenly in core or progressively you
know over the 60s and 70s that it
finally you know came to a head in 1973
when they said we've had enough you know
these people were invading the
psychiatrist's office and saying doc
cure me
I got a problem I'm homosexual and the
guy the doc would say you know I don't
know there's nothing I can give you I
have no potion to give you and and so
you know these people had no solution
and the solution was to make to remove
homosexuality from the list of mental
disorders okay they alleging that it
wasn't supposed to be there in the first
place but again they never did a an
analysis of the numbers if the numbers
are increasing that is a problem you
can't say it's not a mental disorder if
the numbers are increasing if they
always stayed level you could probably
make an argument but not if they're
increasing their increasing the other
problem and the problem is is here let
me show it again
the problem is that you know if if this
is on the rise if homosexuality
underwrites right there at the bottom
you can do sister population decline
okay okay Calhoun John Calhoun he's a
psychologist an ecologist and
psychologists he studied how ecology
affects our mental state and he created
homosexuality in the lab and autism
right and some of the parameters that
you might consider the ones that I
included my analysis are density which
is a nurture issue in other words that
affects you through the eyes it's
external but then you have all these
other ones which are genetically related
which are what I call nature founders
effect in
okay the the mice and the rats that he
used throughout his 30-year career
analyzing his animals they were
inbreeding they had no one else to breed
with then you have to look at the
genetic diversity of the seed that he
use of the Ford he put four couples
heterosexual couples and a few
generations later he got homosexuals out
of those four original what you could
call the seed and so the question is how
much diversity did the seed already have
before he put them in there okay I mean
how many millions of years or thousands
of years have the mice been around when
was the species created like you know
for humans we say two hundred thousand
years well how long have the mice been
around have they been for around for two
hundred thousand years like if we go 200
thousand years in the past with that
Mouse two hundred thousand years ago
with would he be able to interbreed with
a mouse today or vice versa
you know and then having offering it off
bringing the old age I'm not sure
Calhoun looked at these little details
and I think that's got to be a little
more controlled anyways
inbreeding among the Mamas is known to
have created all these genetic and
mental diseases that they have today
including homosexuality and these people
started 300 years ago that's when they
came to America about 1500 families and
today you know 300 years later here we
have all kinds of genetic mental disease
genetic mental and physical okay
diseases including homosexuality among
the Amish and so it shows that there's
been an increase or a changing some in
something that needs to be looked at and
homosexuality is abnormal why is it
abnormal because I say so
know itself normal because plants don't
have sex for to have fun they do it for
exclusively for procreation and again if
it's homosexuality is on the rise it
conduces to population decline
have a problem with if homosexuality if
homosexuals are becoming a greater
percentage of our population and my my
conclusion is that homosexuality appears
towards the end of a species cycle what
the species has exhausted its genetic
diversity and there's two cases in point
lions and sheep you find homosexuality
among them and the Lions you know they
went from what is it from about a
hundred fifty thousand fifty years ago
to only thirty five thousand today
that's all the lines we have on earth
and in the wild pressure zoos have
relatively few lions so if you look at
all the lines in the world you know the
stock has gone down and so these animals
these lions are essentially inbreeding
and then you have the case of the sheep
as well the Rams about eight percent of
them eight percent of the Rams are
homosexual thus
someone said ten of anywhere between
eight and ten percent are homosexual and
the question is why because there's tons
of Rams in the world the issue is that
we've been ingredient we've been
selectively we've been doing a
artificial selection on them you know
around the world and so they're losing
their genetic diversity as well because
we're inbreeding them almost
deliberately for different reasons that
right we don't in breed lines but we
kind of closed in on their territory and
they don't have as much room such much
land and they've killed them all so for
prizes and to put them on the walls and
whatever and so are as mattress carpets
and so you know the lion population has
declined quite drastically in fact I
think they're on the way out ok ok so
that's that's the summary ok and have
status as I see it that's what I said
last week let's go with the comments and
I'm gonna start with a comment that
someone made and I want to address this
issue and he says I would appear that my
earlier comment was deleted either by
some YouTube error because I was editing
it
and then it just vanished or by bill no
I don't delete comments okay I don't
delete comments and but let me qualify
that okay there were people who in when
I started on YouTube they came in argued
okay no problem we argued back and forth
back and forth and I did this with lots
of people I have a million comments in
in several in almost all my first videos
and then what happened these people were
not happy or they wanted to play a joke
on me or whatever and they deleted their
side of the comments so they went in
there and they took the trouble to lead
their side of the comment and I ended up
talking to no one know there was someone
who would have read would have read me
answering the law and so I had to delete
my comments as well and at that point I
decided to delete a lot of the comments
because people were doing that then I
had the experience of hub pages I put a
lot of articles there and people came in
and they discussed things and at some
point I stopped answering I just didn't
answer anymore it turns out that when
they I get called by hub pages the
administration they say you know that
they're gonna punish me they're gonna
penalize me because I'm not taking care
of my site and the issue was that some
people came in during the argument he
started cussing each other and I was not
even aware of it I mean you know there
were so many comments and hub pages
didn't like all that cussing and they
said I had to patrol it and I said screw
you I did it very simply I wiped out all
the comments and I don't accept comments
anymore in fact they have to be approved
and I won't approve any comments on hub
pages on any of my articles and then I
had the same thing happens or something
similar happened to me in Korah a couple
people came in and they started talking
to me and I answered back and and I
treated them really with respect I just
gave them my opinion in fact I looked at
the what I said I didn't insult them or
anything because I know that was part of
Korra's policy well this gal came in and
she she argued than me
and I and I told her what I thought
about it and I just gave her my opinion
but my opinion offended her and she went
and she protested it in Quora and
fortunately korra just laughed at her
and didn't pay attention to her but
another guy was a little more successful
he was an Indian fella and he his
English wasn't so good so I guess he
didn't understand what I was telling him
and he was offended because he was this
doctor his PhD and I am and I was
telling him that you know a lot of pH
needs didn't know much of physics and I
told them where the problems were
especially with some of these heroes
that we have in mathematical physics and
he went complained to her Cora and they
came back and they advised me not to be
so direct and so I stopped putting
comments there I don't know a lot of
comments in Cora as well whenever I see
one of my articles that still has
comments I delete them all and wipe them
out
I only accept comments at patreon right
now that's the only place I will answer
them in you - I accept comments but I
don't answer them
okay and by the way I do want to thank
the patreon supporters and there's not
too many of them I mean I'm gonna become
a millionaire with patreon and they're
not gonna lose much money because I only
request one dollar if I could request 10
cents which is just a token I would do
it but patron only allows when one but
and the only reason for that is so that
they maintain this channel alive the day
that I have no one contribute putting
their money where their mouth is with
one measly buck was because then I'm not
doing a good job and that's when I have
to close down the show so anyways I
think my patreon supporters thank you
guys and I'll keep running as long as
you know everybody is content with the
material I cover here and again your you
know anyone in patreon knows that they
can suggest topics and so on anyways
let's get on with it
here was another comment okay and this
is a more lengthy comment for me
to answer okay says if homosexuality is
increasing in some way because of lower
diversity that would imply that such
sexual identity condition is physical
and not mental agreed yeah yeah on the
other hand if it's considered to be
strictly a mental condition due to abuse
or whatever you know some social thing
some environmental thing Hollywood
exposure or whatever then it cannot be
said to be a sign of genetic diversity
agreed again okay of course there are
quite complex interactions between
genetic variation and behavior and agree
there as well so I agree with all of
them what's the issue well the issue is
that first of all I gotta put this up
here my son and I and we debate this
issue of nature versus nurture and he's
on the nurture side I'm on the nature
side and we don't see eye to eye after
many discussions on this issue what's
the issue the issue is that you know I'm
saying it's primarily genetic and he
says it's primarily social and he's
referring to the fact in the last 20-30
years the Internet has gone you know
through the roof everybody is on the
internet and all that information we
receive all that distance all that what
is it social distances that we get
through the internet separates us and
does some damage to our brains or people
get used to it and and this affects
their brains in some way and we both
agree that it's not all nature and it's
not all nurture we don't think it's 100%
I'm just saying that most of it is
nature it's got to do with your genetics
the fact that we have no genetic
diversity today
I think that's causing a lot of the
problems that we see today not only
homosexuality but you have the case of
autism and even if you don't take autism
you take the case of people who have
more men more severe mental problems
like Down syndrome we're getting more
not only gentle genetic problems but
also physical genetic problem we're
seeing the rarest diseases that we've
ever seen and part of that yeah and what
blinds us is the fact that we have so
much population so you would expect more
variation in a higher population so all
these things are things that need to be
discussed in a lot of detail okay but
yeah we don't see eye to eye on this
issue completely and we always discuss
it over beers okay and so so let's get
on with something here which we can say
is the way the brain works okay and what
I'm gonna argue here is that genetics
whether genetics are social really it
doesn't matter if it's nature or nurture
it's got to go through the cells first
there is no standalone object called
consciousness there is no standalone
object called mind or thought or spirit
or soul or whatever you want to call it
okay
that's concept specifically a dynamic
concept and that concept is created
inside the brain so we got to look at
the brain because without the brain you
have no consciousness there is again no
standalone spirit here soul that goes to
heaven separate from your body but
that's what most religious people have
in the back of their minds so that's the
first thing we need to clarify for the
purposes of physics for a rational
discussion okay and so here I'm gonna
put the this gif here and I'm gonna show
you that what happens here is how we
have the brain okay let's wait till it
starts here's the brain okay and the
brain if you go deeper into it you'll
find lots of neurons and you look at
these neurons they look more or less
like this right
okay so we've more or less seen their
stuff all of us you know you got the
brain if you could have God's eyes and
go deeper in there you would see this
network
wiring this is neurons which are not
actually touching each other because
they're separated by this synapses right
Sidney synapse in between many of them
right and and then you have you know if
you go deeper you go you're gonna see a
single neuron okay and that's what I'd
like to look into right now here see if
I can see this one okay and what you see
between two neurons is this synapse the
gap between two neurons okay and so here
you have two neurons if you go deeply in
there you see they're not touching
really each other and I've separated
them for much more distance and what
they really are in actuality but
essentially the two neurons do not touch
each other there is a gap there and that
gap is known as that synapse okay and
what's happening here is two things you
have you have electrical and you have
chemical things going through that
barrier and the chemical more or less
they pinpoint it because they can
measure that somehow or see it to some
degree you're talking about molecules
here chemicals but the electrical is the
is the big problem because electrical
they can't see and of course all these
doctors all these researchers what do
they do well they have to without be an
expert they say well let's see what is
electricity and they go to quantum they
have to go to quantum to find out what
electricity is it and they just take the
party line and said oh it's a flow of
electrons and we can't see electrons so
they say okay the electrons are flowing
through these channels that are between
to two of these two of these neurons and
yeah you have the little action tips and
you have the dendrites okay and they're
separated just by a tease you in GB and
a question and one of the big problems
is that they've discovered and they know
for a fact okay and they say it every
that the electricity goes both ways
through those channels so not only does
the weather on the receiving end
supposedly the receiving end Neutron
neuron receive it but also the the one
that's right behind it they both receive
the signal simultaneously and how do you
do that with electricity you have a like
it's like running electricity through
the same wire
can you run electricity in both
directions simultaneously that's what
they're saying is happening okay keep
that in mind okay here we go to the this
other one okay and this shows you what's
happening from electrical synapse okay
I'm not gonna be concerned about the
chemical synapse here okay so I'm gonna
brush that one aside we're only gonna
look at the electrical synapse and what
you see there is that the electricity
goes both ways that's what those arrows
represent okay okay and so you have
electricity going both ways and here you
stop that so that you can see it there
okay which means that you know these
electrons are really going in both
directions I want you to understand that
it's like having a wire and it's having
you know electricity flow both ways okay
this is the quantum version yeah you
have electricity flowing both ways
through that channel see if you can
explain it I guess like sending wire
through a wire electricity in both
directions we're not talking about AC
where the direction changes from moment
to moment we're saying simultaneously
electricity goes both ways
okay and so I have to put in my rope
version okay and here's the Rope version
of that oh sorry wrong one where is it
here it is sorry
the Rope version okay and you can see
that Y goes both ways because it's
turning in place and he gives you
whether you measure one region or the
other you're gonna feel a torsion that's
it all the interconnected atoms they are
merged merge electron shells and they're
spinning in place in situ and you're
gonna be able to measure that on both
sides because electricity runs both ways
under the rope model of light and also
light goes both ways
under oak model of light okay so the the
it's a different mechanism than proposed
by quantum where is the flow of little
beads known as electron particles and
here we have all these merged electron
shells in there they're all connected in
what we call serpentine and they're
twirling in place and no matter where
you look at it you're gonna find
electricity and one place you got found
the positive pole the other when the
negative pole which is really what is it
clockwise and counter clockwise that's
all it is
so Mother Nature doesn't understand
positive negative
mother nature understands clockwise and
counter clockwise that's physics the
other nonsense is mathematics okay okay
I think that brain functions pretty much
like a like a transistor okay so we have
all these cells in there within the
cells we have these neurons and so you
know these neurons they communicate
instantaneously you could say in Septon
ously you picture your toe and you feel
that immediately in your brain in other
words the connection is instantaneous
and that's not the chemical part of the
neurons
that's the electrical neurons okay
that's the electrical part of the
neurons and one guy pointed out I didn't
have time to put his comment here but he
pointed out that you know that there's
no magnetism that there's only
electricity between two neurons he's
wrong everywhere where we have
electricity we have magnetism there's no
way to avoid it
and so he should learn the basics the
basics is wherever you have electricity
you have a what is known as a magnetic
field there's no way to avoid that and
so if electricity is flowing let me put
this up again if electricity is flowing
up and down here vertically what you
have is the threads which make up the
magnetic field and they go sideways they
hope they are swinging horizontally in
that picture
I didn't illustrate that but I'm just
saying that that's the what is what it
is okay just so you get the total
picture so know there's always magnetism
where there's electricity there is no
way you can avoid that
yeah one thing creates the other in fact
it was Faraday and later on and before
here mom what's the other fella I lost
his name now but they already show that
one induces the other into being okay
that's where Maxwell also got his
equations okay and here's the here's a
transistor okay and you can see this was
the letter A this is how it's done with
eight bits a transistors to simplify
things it's a little more complicated
than this but and if you want the letter
B well you've got to have this other
thing and if you compare them you can
see there's a difference between the a
and the B okay the a has the last
transistor turned on with a 1 that means
this guy's probably more than half of
all ditch these in my days and the B has
the same thing but in the next of the
last one okay so that's how you create
these the signals for the computer to
read them so it would know the
difference between an A and a B okay and
and yeah here you see it you know the
difference between a and B okay okay I
say the neurons are more or less this I
think work in a similar way as a
transistor I think in that sense humans
have been able to imitate mother nature
not perfectly obviously you know we
don't make neurons but as closely as
possible a transistor I think pretty
much simulates adora okay so here we
have a bunch of neurons and we can
assume those into are in the brain okay
and the way I think I see this working
is something like this you know they one
is turning on the other one is off and
they have to be somehow in other words
they have to be related you can't have a
neuron just all by itself processing
some kind of information I think the way
the brain works is you have maybe two
three four probably millions of neurons
turn on at a given time and then turning
off one the other guy turns on and and
so on and I think this is what creates
our thinking right inside the brain and
this is from this is where you get
thought okay it's the combination of
these it's just the same as far as I'm
concerned it's pretty much the same as a
transistor you know one transistor turns
on and the other one is off because it's
got zero voltage and the other one is
zero voltage the other one zero voltage
the other one has a one because it's got
maybe 0.5 volts and so with this
combination I mean the transistors don't
move around okay inside a computer what
they do is it when turns on the other
one turns off and this is in this
combination this series of combinations
is what creates the information that you
get out of your computer and I'm saying
something similar is probably happening
inside the brain and again you know I'm
saying you know what turns on the other
one turns off and so on and they form
these patterns and it's these patterns
that you know is what we call thinking
okay that's that's my five cents worth
okay that's the way I see it and again
between the synapses between two neurons
you have the synapse and then synapse
the electrical part I am saying is is
they're not completely isolated they're
connected but they're connected by what
they're connected by a series of
electron shells which form serpentines
that are spinning at great speeds and of
course we can't see
at the atomic level so for us it's
invisible what we're seeing we're
probably seeing hydrogen atoms or or
something very small and they're turning
around and that's that's the electrical
signal that connects these two neurons
okay so I'm saying the synapse is not a
completely empty space as they say in
the researchers who do all this stuff
I'm saying there's something there we
just can't see it and there had better
be something if you're gonna feel the
pain from your toe all the way in your
brain
there better be a complete connection
physical connection and you know they
use again concepts to to deal with these
explanations this these physical
interpretations okay
certain areas of the brain and they deal
with love this this is theorized they've
done a lot of experiments out there and
observations and a more or less mapped
the brain they say look these regions
are the regions that deal with love and
of course they have to be in unison in
other words not all not all of these or
probably none of these are separate in
other words they have to work together
these regions and so they have you can
call them Oregon's almost because each
one has its function and but it can't do
it so let's thing alone if it's not
connected to this other organ in this
other organ which are different parts of
the brain that deal with emotions with
love with pity empathy and so on anger
and I think these are the regions that
have to work together one has to turn on
maybe the other one has to turn on to
some degree so much voltage whatever it
is in there you know they have to more
or less work together to create this
thought and in the case of love these
regions have been mapped and that's
where we can find you know how
homosexuality might be working it is
Hamas is the brain of a homosexual
different than a brain of a heterosexual
you know you have to look at that you're
gonna say well are their brains
different because I
what's creating the thought that's what
creating the emotion why is this guy
attracted to men instead of to women you
know and again I'm saying he was born
that way again I've said that last week
I have no problem with that I think he
was born at Wayne great measure because
it's a genetic problem in a if you would
have been you know god you're gonna say
well it's predictable when when these
guys lose their genetic diversity
they're gonna have mutations and these
mutations are going to cause these
homosexual prop orientations okay and so
I'm saying it all starts in the brain
okay it starts in the brain you got to
modify the brain the only issue now is
whether you can modify the brain through
Nature Genetics or are you going to
modify the brain through social
environment density in a case of Calhoun
he did it through density did that have
an effect on the mice or was it just
founders effect and these are the issues
that need to be discussed in quite a bit
of detail right and or maybe do some
more research maybe testing and
everybody then reaches their own
conclusions okay we do know for a fact
that sheep and lions are homosexual you
have about 8% of rams and I don't know
how many lines but I know there's quite
a bit of lions that lately have been
found to have sex between male lions
also apparently between female lions and
the quit one question pops in my mind at
least is that no one noticed this
behavior in the past in other words no
one documented homosexuality amongst
lions or sheep hundreds of years ago and
again it makes me wonder whether this is
a new phenomenon and I think it is a new
phenomena in a case of lions again they
brought their population so now they're
they have less genetic diversity and
it's expected that you know the the more
we have the fewer lines there are I
think the more
probably will find among stumps among
them you know genetic physical problems
and then also mental problems and one of
those is obviously homosexuality if
homosexuality is invading the world of
the Lions obviously that's not going to
work in favor of reproduction and then
yes as far as genetic problems I can
only testify to a couple things that I
saw it there female lions which are born
with Mane's like the male lion they have
a beard okay so I think that's a genetic
problem okay and I think it's got to do
I don't think we were came
I don't want ten thousand years ago we
would have found lionesses with Mane's
that probably we would have found
homosexual lions this is something new
okay
and in the case of sheep it's because
you know we in breed them okay we we
select say oh no I want a good sheep I'm
gonna use this macho guy and all the
others you know they're gonna have to
masturbate because I'm not gonna worry
about them I'm gonna use this guy's
semen and we do that with cows we do
that with lots of animals horses you
know we read them for horse racing and
so on so we're doing a lot of selective
evolution here on our own we're fighting
against Mother Nature and what we're
doing is essentially killing these these
species these species are not going to
last another million years no way okay
there were Studies on humans rats mice
and a few other animals and there we
found that there is a difference between
the brain of a heterosexual and that of
a homosexual and it's got to do with
with this it's known as the the sexually
dimorphic nucleus okay and here's a one
testimony and there's several articles
on this you can find them on the end
okay in rats the most studied aspect of
brain masculinization is the development
of the male typical sexually dimorphic
nucleus of the medial preoptic area
which is five times I guess he meant
five times larger and male rats than in
females okay in addition the number of
dendritic spines and axial spinous
synapses in preoptic neurons is greater
in male rats than in females sexually
dimorphic nuclear have also been
described in the medial preoptic
anterior hypothalamus of other
vertebrates best species including
humans okay and then you'll find that
this sexually dimorphic nucleus you'll
see many reports articles on this issue
that it's different from homosexuals to
heterosexuals and here's one mention of
this of the preoptic area was discovered
in rats and has been found to be larger
in males at least nine different species
including humans and now your most
California Mouse and there's a fellow
his name is dick swab I think he's
Belgian or Swedish I think he's Swedish
and then swab says that he says that he
is that a quite a bit of study on this
and you should look him up dick swab and
what he's done is what I'm one of his
studies he took the brains of many
people who died he was able to get a
license to get get this done yeah you
went to the morgue and just you know
collected brains of heterosexuals and
known homosexuals and he found that this
dimorphic nucleus the sexually dimorphic
nucleus was smaller in homosexuals and
very similar in this sense to females
now whether that's being corroborated I
had no chance to look at that but these
are things you got to look at from a
structural from a morphological point of
view in other words uh physiological if
if the brain if some parts of the
rain in critical loved areas are smaller
and homosexuals than they are in
heterosexuals well then you might be
getting close to a cause for why they
are attracted to males and not to
females there could be an issue there
that obviously needs to be investigated
and if that's the case well then the
next step is finding out why these
people have these regions of the brain
with a smaller diamond nucleus and my
guess is that it has to do with
mutations and these mutations are caused
by the fact that we've exhausted our
genetic diversity meaning that we're at
the end of the line as a species ok
that's my take on that
ok just just so you know where I'm
coming from with all this ok what's next
give me a second here ok I'm done with
that let's move on to other comments
here ok and here's the fella says the
Romans were extremely concerned with
homosexuality and had a culture with
strictly sexual code which obviously
suggests that homosexuals were
significant enough in number to be of
concern to the rulers that's not the way
I see it I don't I I have a different
take on this I'm saying that all the old
cultures they saw some homosexuality no
doubt about it in my mind something
happened at least eleven hundred years
before Christ you know maybe three
thousand years ago or so that's when I
think this problem this issue became a
problem they started including it in the
codes in the legal codes and my my take
on that is that it's not that the
numbers worrying they were so great it's
that I think they found it disgusting
repugnant and I think no different in
that sense that today lots of people
find it repugnant and
and so you know if they were to write
the code they were writing in the same
way today as they did in the old days
because they they simply it's not a
question of numbers it's a question of
that they found it disgusting right so
that's my take on that I don't think
it's got to do with numbers again - even
today I put some numbers the other day
and numbers vary widely from country a
country so I don't know how much weight
to put on those numbers but I think you
could say that maybe anywhere from 6 to
15 percent of the population in any
given country or general in the world is
probably homosexual and by homosexual I
mean transsexual by sex or the whole
gamut you know they're not heterosexuals
so we'll call non heterosexuals how's
that I think anywhere between I don't
know maybe 5 to 15% that's that's my
guess and I don't know why you know the
numbers vary so widely again polls have
to be treated with a pinch of salt ok ok
another comment says I've rarely come
across gay people that are deficient in
intellect or ability most gay couple
people I've known are superior to
regular folks in body mind art and
kindness most straight people have
serious mental problems and engage in
violence crime hypocrisy racism
corruption and ignorance yeah you know I
don't I don't do politics I don't judge
them you know again I can't judge them
because I believe that they were born
that way I would say at least 95 percent
of them were born that way and I've had
a couple cases one was a boss that we
had and my last boss at Intel he was
homosexual but I mean not just
homosexual he was homosexual here is
this and this guy the day he came to our
department he gave us a presentation you
know with with
screen there and the guy put up there
among the things I'm gay and it's like
we all looked at each other like saying
uh-huh and and the guys just mentioned a
couple things about that and a couple of
women they were very they were
Christians when when we walked out of
there they were upset there so what's he
got to bring all this stuff about gay
that he's gay and he really didn't have
to say it because if you saw walk down
the aisle you would say this guy's gay
he just had it in his genes there's no
way you can tell me that guy was
educated to be like that no that guy was
born like that and so when I see some of
these extreme cases you know over the
mannered men you know these guys are
born that way there's no way that guy
was educated to be like that at least
that's that's my take okay that's all I
could tell you I don't accept that that
the guy was educated like that and again
I mentioned the guy in Rosario the other
day that that you know when it got me
started on this issue of homosexuality
this guy this guy yeah I didn't notice
anything in him my wife apparently did
but but I did and you know some people
you do notice some people you don't and
whether that's you can say that that was
learned you know you learned it at
school or where do you learn this
sexuality thing you know now you're born
with it and I can only budge for myself
in that sense I know my experience I was
nine years old when when I got in
head-over-heels over this girl next door
she had just moved into the in Baltimore
she had just moved next door to us and
she was the cutest thing ever in in your
life you know in that you ever saw and
and there were like three of us you know
we were I was nine years old there was
my buddy grant and another fellow tax
daily and and we were around we were all
lusting for her and we were only nine
years old and we were all head over
heels over this girl she was seven years
old
so beautiful girl but that's nature no
one thought you know we had no
discussions with my parents about sex or
anything like that we never discussed
the subject especially we never
discussed homosexuality so we had
nothing a fit in favor or against it was
just a nun subject nobody talked about
sexuality and in the 60s especially
homosexuality so now my personal
experience is these things you're born
with it whatever you're born just be
lucky if if you believe if you're
against homosexual be lucky that you're
not that you weren't born one period
you're done okay thank thank the good
old Lord up there he didn't give you all
these things yeah then you should have
had okay here's another comment okay and
especially the one on the bottom well
first one says the alphabet people due
to social engineering again I think it's
more nature than nurture but you know
everybody's got opinions on this and the
guy in the bottom says here there was an
autism until the 30s when stroke mercury
fluorescent lights came through
residential use the Amish don't use
electricity and so no autism well the
Amish have a little bigger problem than
autism and they're all mental problems
here you first you see the physical
problems here's one the six finger kids
they have the bank Krefeld crevel the
disease several cases in the Amish world
and that's all got to do with genetics
I'm hopefully hopefully that wasn't
something that was caused by the street
lamps okay and then you have this other
one and here let me put this up it's a
mp4 so let me turn it on hold on give me
a second here and I'll keep my mouth
shut
take for example the Pilar girls these
three Amish sisters were all born with a
condition that mysterious leads to
severe mental retardation and a host of
physical problems so this is Betty Ann
yes she's 24 and she functions at a nine
month level nine month
Irma is 22 and functions as a
five-year-old girl and Linda at age 19
can't even sit up let alone talk what do
you think of that
how much have lots of problems and not
only these three girls there's other
cases there are doctor genetic doctors
working with the Amish community and the
Amish still insists that they're not
going to do any testing prenuptial
testing if they get some of these
genetic diseases they're gonna put their
faith in God yeah that's the way they
look at it anyways there are mental
problems and there are homosexuals among
Amish I pointed that out the other day
they have an organization homosexual and
transsexual Amish so you know this
notion that there's no autism among
Amish well I don't know about how to the
autism but they've got bigger problems
in autism and so maybe they wish they
had autism and I think again that has to
do with genetics and not with street
lamps at least that's my take okay
another comment moving on here okay and
this fella says all the animals from the
universe cannot connect just a single
atom okay we're going now into more main
main line or mainstream physics here
we're talking about physics now and why
not the question is why why can't all
atoms be connected here here's the
difference between
quantum mechanics especially and the
rope model okay a mathematical physics
you have discrete particles do all those
atoms throw particles at one atom I mean
there's one atom receive light from all
atoms in the universe whether you see
them or not because if all atoms in the
universe are throwing particles radially
then we all have to be hit by every atom
in the universe okay so I'm not sure how
you can avoid that and so this notion
that oh this this can't be you know
first of all it's just an opinion and
second in science what we do is we make
an assumption but even if you know if
you want to disregard those you would
have to answer why one atom could avoid
all the light being sent from every atom
in the universe you know it should be
hit by every atom in the universe
whether you know even if you believe in
photons or whatever so now you can't
avoid it yeah under the rope model all
atoms are interconnected and therefore
one atom is connected to all others no
way to avoid it
okay here's another comment Hey
moving on read this sound waves in the
air also always fall down as no one is
holding the other side of the string or
is that due to gravity what is he
talking about well I mentioned that give
my rope here that in order to do let me
get this one out of here in order to do
a sine wave in other words to do a
standing wave you got to do it like this
right
what does that mean it means that you've
got to hold the other end if this is
more or less straight or along the same
axis because if I let go and I don't get
a straight wave going anymore I can't I
can't do it like this I have to hold the
other end okay that was my argument and
he says well you
a sound and it travels straight and you
don't have to hold the other end yeah
that's that's his notion and here let me
show you the waves
let's compare one against the other okay
and again here you have the first one
that's the longitudinal wave at the top
and the transverse wave at the bottom
transverse wave moves up and down
perpendicular to the direction of travel
of the whole way right whereas the
longitudinal way just moves back and
forth okay and so the the question here
is whether whether the one on the top
requires that you attach it at the other
end that's the issue is raising okay and
again you know if I were to simulate it
right let's see here if I were to
simulate it with a slinky okay well you
know I would have to hold the other end
because otherwise I get the same thing
you know I can't do it and that in that
if I'm if I'm to simulate it but he says
well in air you don't have to hold it
because air is not a continuous medium
right like you know stretchable or
whatever it's it's not a medium that is
made of a single piece in other words
right and so the issue here is that
sound waves are a little different
because yeah they move radially okay but
they move radially and they move maybe
along each one of those you could say is
a straight line but we don't know if
they're a straight line they've up and
down they move in all directions because
there's this amplitude in there and what
is the amplify can you hear me and
distinguish each one you know I don't
have monotonous sounds it it goes up and
down you can hear my intonation might
peach many things here and and that's
because it's being compressed and
expanded but again you also have the
issue of you know gazillions of atoms
that are here in the air which conducts
the the sound right and they're moving
up and down in different
directions you know air doesn't doesn't
really go straight area is moving in
every directions a gas so there is no
such thing as straightness in the in the
air when you're hearing sounds okay and
so no I don't agree that you don't that
if you're gonna simulate you're gonna
need you know like the slinky you're
gonna need to hold it at the other end
otherwise you won't be able to do this
you're gonna get this okay it's gonna go
down you got to hold it in order to
produce the the longitudinal wave okay
otherwise you can't do it and sound air
you know there there is no straightness
to it okay okay
next common let's see if we can find it
here again so many of these we're gonna
say okay here goes it comes from the
Flat Earth Society day and what does the
flat earther say he says can you uh
scientifically prove that the earth is a
globe pictures are not scientific proof
no of course not
and we don't rely on pictures okay what
we rely on is reasoning and we have to
explain a mechanism or a cause right and
among them we have to explain you know
why water curves around the planet one
of the issues that flat earthers raise
almost every two seconds oh how can you
curve water look I tried it in my
bathroom it doesn't work
yeah no kid you don't have the mass and
they don't understand that okay so he
says can you repeat the gravity
experiment that proves it exists
okay and he insists on proving that the
earth is a globe okay how do we do this
in in rational science okay and let's
see if I can get this here's a one
picture that gives you the idea of why
yay why the earth is round spherical
more or less okay and what picture is
worth a thousand words and here we're
not talking about taking a snapshot I'm
that's got nothing to do with with
taking a snapshot it's got to do with
the theory or with the assumption okay
and the assumption is that all atoms are
inter connected physically
interconnected by an electromagnetic
rope now we can explain why the Chinese
man on the other side of the planet is
pulled towards the center of the earth
and so are we which are standing in
opposite direction to him and here it is
okay picture is worth a thousand words
and there you have it okay we're all
pulled towards the center of the earth
because every atom on earth is pulling
on you
that means the Chinese man on the other
side of the planet every atom in his
body is connected to every atom in your
body right through the center of the
earth more or less okay because you know
he may not be exactly a hundred eighty
degrees from you but here it explains to
you why we don't fly out of the earth
because we're all connected to the
center okay and why if you jump you fall
back down because you know you're tied
to every atom and again I'm not gonna go
into details of gravity but I've talked
about that in the past but this is a
picture that shows you why the earth
must and cannot be otherwise then round
okay and then you have another picture
okay and this has to do with the
atmosphere and water okay and here I
think it synthesizes quite well okay and
I use that the other day in my Spanish
Channel and why the atmosphere sticks to
the earth as well as water okay the
oceans why don't do those drops of water
just fly out and the reason is clear
every atom in our atmosphere is
connected to the center of the earth or
to every atom on earth okay
and so the atoms cannot just fly away
because they're physically connected to
the earth
any gas for that matter is that is close
to the earth because the earth has so
much mass so many atoms and every atom
in the atmosphere every single atom in
the atmosphere is connected to every
atom that makes up you can say the solid
earth and the same goes for water so
that's why it they don't go flying out
and you know whenever you doubt that you
can always use what we call authority
and here you have authority here you
have mr. Miller
he's from Berkeley and he tells you how
it works the mathematics of it but it's
the same thing his interpretation is
correct that's as far as I'm concerned
so for example if you have the earth
here there's this big mass here talking
about the Big M the earth and you have
you with your little mass here and
that's you standing on the earth every
atom on earth is pulling on every atom
of you every atom on Earth is pulling on
every atom of you and of course Miller
doesn't know what he said he hasn't he
hasn't thought about what he said
because he is and the reason is clear he
never thought that there is an atom
connecting to another atom because he
sees nothing between them that's the
issue he doesn't see any connector
between an atom that is in our
atmosphere and an atom on the ground for
example there is between those two atoms
he doesn't see anything he says there's
nothing there now there is something
there you just can't see it you can't
touch it because the electromagnetic
rope is not touchable or seeable it's a
rope in other words it's a thing it's an
object only because it has shaped not
because of tangibility or visibility and
he asks you you're also pulling on it
the amazing thing about gravity is that
it goes right throw things the only way
you can get that is if every atom is
physically interconnected to all others
straight forward rope hypothesis
explains it with flying colors no
problem there another comment I think
this one also comes from the Flat Earth
but it's got to do with a tangential
subject here it's got to do with
electricity and this guy says yeah we've
already come to the conclusion in a flat
earth community that the motion of the
sky the firmament is where the electric
charge of our world comes from so we
have this electric charge that's
creating a I guess a voltage across the
atmosphere I don't know exactly how they
visualize this and so the earth is
negative and I guess the firmament or
the whatever is out there is positive
yeah and it is our world comes from
emanating from the one true direction
and source north okay so from the north
that's where all this differential comes
from okay and so he thinks that gravity
is electricity
just like the electric universe they
think that gravity is addressing Honorio
just like extending Earth's atmosphere
to be on the moon to help explain
certain impossible observation what is
thank you so long ad well I'll tell you
what's taking so long and I did a little
experiment the other day in my Spanish
Channel I'm just gonna put it up here
okay and you'll see what happens here
okay see if it starts from the start in
the middle but you'll see what happens
first I threw some papers then I threw
the balloon I show they both fall to the
earth to the table there and then what I
did was I created some static
electricity there I throw the papers
okay I created some static electricity
with a balloon after you know after I
try to pick them up the papers with a
balloon and it would pick them up
because if the balloon is positive and
the papers are positive and the earth is
negative then the balloon should repel
the the papers and you can see it
doesn't do anything to them it's only
after I create some static electricity
that
the balloon picks up the papers and they
can't both be positive because you can
see we drop the papers and we drop the
balloon and they all fall is it
continued to fall towards the earth
towards the center of the earth okay one
more time here just in case we drop the
papers they fall okay we drop the
balloon it falls okay so they're all
positive but positive does not repel
positive in order to get some
interference here to some interaction I
had to rub the balloon and now yet picks
it up but then both the balloon and the
papers continue to fall to the earth so
we got a problem with saying that
gravity is our Chrissy and I'm not sure
what counter-argument the loonies of the
electric universe come up with but there
you have proof evidence experiment
everything they wanted to show that the
earth cannot be negative like they are
yeah okay
another comment lots of comments ahead
this week okay on every aspect he came
science is the scientific method and
alternative made-up story is not science
meaning my version yeah you're a hundred
percent wrong okay good opinion theory
that's definitely not one of the steps
of the scientific method theory we don't
do explanations he says that's not what
science is about in fact the only thing
science actually requires is observation
and experimentation that's what he says
it has been said if you don't have
experimentation you don't have science
your stupid theories are not science
okay guy got a little upset with my
theories okay it's okay just take two
aspirins call me in the morning
okay okay so what do I have to say about
that well here's the first one and
that's that today we have no definition
of science from the mainstream here you
have three definitions one talks about
systematic study the other one says it's
organization of knowledge the other one
says observing watching listening what
in other words they put everything in
this thing called science and nobody has
a scientific definition of the word
science that's the problem okay
and so what we had to do was define
science and we define it as rational
explanations okay and we have two
branches when it's physics the other one
is philosophy physics deals with objects
and tries to explain causes and
mechanisms rationally what is rationally
means objectively means that you can
watch a movie and understand the
mechanism we're done that's how we
explain how a magnet attracts another
how gravity works etc philosophy will
out deals primarily with concepts that's
the bread and butter and the building
block and it deals with reasons of
purpose okay
so that's in a nutshell what we're
proposing okay and that's different than
the mainstream which still has no
definition of science and says science
is everything and everything we want it
to be it's observation its prediction
it's mathematics they say mathematics is
the language of science at all physics
so they have this this a wide range of
definitions or notions of what science
is and nobody gives a damn because
nobody has defined the word science
that's the problem
and so this fella was just brainwashed
in high school or wherever this just
repeat that science is experimentation
and observation so I do an experiment
said I always do that just to make sure
that I destroy his argument completely
ok here here's a we're gonna use this
ball so I'm gonna do an experiment okay
I'm gonna let the ball fall yeah I got
it held here by this little rubber band
okay and I'm gonna let it fall okay
okay Paul so if I let go with the ball
it does fall okay and you don't have to
believe me I'm not doing this in
Hollywood or in you can take a ball let
go you'll find that it goes to the floor
so you can do this a million times
okay so I did a repeatable
experiment is that something you know
you observed it yeah yeah I observe you
want me to observe it again I'll do it
for the millionth time here okay so I
did the experiment let's say I did a
thousand times I observed it a thousand
times is that science so I so I watched
birds every day you know and I find that
they make nests
I observed did I learn anything maybe I
haven't learned anything you know maybe
I don't understand why they make nests
so observing Anna grunting experiments
is is a no-brainer
you know describing also no-brainer I
can describe a chair is that science so
no science where you have to break your
brain is is try to figure out not what
the magician did on on stage you know
yeah he cut the lady in half he pulled a
rabbit out of the Hat okay yeah that's
science no science is telling me how he
did the tricks that's where you have to
break your brain see how did he do that
that when you figure that out then
you're a scientist but to say that you
pulled a rabbit out of a hat or kept a
lady in half that's that's just stating
the obvious there's no science there
okay and so that's that's the main point
okay
another mark another comment here I can
get it up here okay here he goes and
this fellow says as you said jumping
kangaroo is not object when breathing
kangaroo also not object or breathing
humans also not object that means we are
all concepts why because you know I'm
saying that you get a in physics we
present objects without motion and he
says everything is moving or more or
less not everything but humans move you
know we breathe so does a kangaroo he
may not jump but he might be breathing
or whatever he misses the point he
doesn't understand what I'm saying okay
this is not an issue of saying that
remove every object in the universe is
movie that's not the point the point is
when you present an object for the
purposes of physics okay you just have
to point a name and here it is okay here
you'll I get this thing up here takes a
while to get these things up here now
that's an object I don't know what it is
all I know it's the only object in the
universe okay there's nothing else so if
there is nothing else I can't even talk
about motion because that thing cannot
move with respect to another object
because there is no other object okay
and so that's an object for the purposes
of physics no motion okay because there
is no other object to compare it against
if there were another object which is
what this fellow is talking about you
know two frames of the film me breathing
is two frames of the film then I have
comparison of two frames here there is
no other frame to compare that whatever
thing is against okay so that's the
point the point is how you present an
object for the purposes of physics the
way you present it your point and name
and at that moment that's the only
object in the universe so you can't say
oh it's moving or I see it no because as
soon as you say that you see it unit
you're evoking a second object or you
touch it you're invoking a second object
you know the the moon doesn't become an
object in that in under that notion
until the asteroid hits it makes a hole
in it then you say oh now they're both
they're two objects there there's an
Astra in the moon well until they hit
they weren't objects that's the issue so
yeah all objects in the universe moves
it's got nothing to do with the argument
here that were the definition of the
word object okay and the guy is again
some people just have no cure for their
mental problems yay
there you go do all objects have mass
well no in fact here I show one object
that doesn't have mass probably a 2d
object you know there's a square have
mass and as a does Bugs Bunny have mass
maybe the pixel does but certainly not
Bugs Bunny
the issue here is that objects for the
purposes of physics is not the objects
were in ordinary speech you can't use
that notion of ordinary speech and bring
it into physics and say oh an object is
that which I can see or touch therefore
I can what I in it has to be weighed and
it has mass that's not an object for the
purposes of physics in physics anything
that has shape is considered an object
and it could be a two-dimensional
non-existent object and it could be a
three-dimensional object could be the
object I'm dreaming there be a
three-dimensional cube I'm thinking of
that's an object ooh I'm dreaming about
kill okay that's an object does it have
mass now because it's just what do we
say a little while ago just a bunch of
neurons sparking there in creating this
thought in my brain so that object does
not exist it's still an object the table
I'm I'm dreaming about that's an object
it's called the table and the word table
always represents an object no matter
where okay there is no such thing as a
tired table that is not an object
they're all objects not all tables have
mass okay not all tables break windows
the one in my head certainly cannot
break the window yeah so it's the word
table it's the words that are classified
as objects the word rope some people say
oh that's a concept no a rope is an
object always hearing on the other side
of the universe rope is always an object
no matter what no matter if you stand on
your head or the word rope always
represents an object okay whereas the
word energy always always always always
represents a concept there is no
physical standalone object called energy
or mass or field that's the issue or
plasma or electricity no such objects in
science you got to understand the
difference between an object and a
concept because otherwise you can't even
start physics and that's where all these
people are okay I think I have my final
question here or comment let's see what
it was I can't remember now oh yeah this
file says I enjoyed Bill Nye as here
because I did Bill
and I also the Tyson okay in the past
weeks it says as he made science fun and
many children in the elementary grades
became interested in science Bill Nye
and Neil deGrasse Tyson opened my eyes
to the flat earth plain reality well
good for you you know yeah again they
can do entertainment I have no problem
with them doing entertainment I have
problem with them calling what they do
science because all they're doing is
regurgitating and spreading the nonsense
of mainstream so called physics
mathematical physics mathematics as we
call it they're telling you about black
holes and dark matter and Big Bang and
other nonsense zero dimensional
particles which come from the future and
who knows what other nonsense they have
because these are their physical
interpretations and these people more or
less use these same things and they feed
them to the public so they are the
people who are serving as mediators
between the people in cameras at Harvard
and the people out on the streets who
don't understand any math and they say
okay what has physics find out you know
and these guys are telling them in
common language what their physical
interpretations are and a lot of these
people most of the people out there
since they don't know much they don't do
any research they take these things at
face value these theories at face value
and that's where I have a problem with
his fault because they're really clowns
that I can understand they want to do
entertainment and they stimulate your
interest in science by I have no problem
with any of that just don't tell me that
they're doing science this is it's a
false advertising okay I think I'm gonna
answer some questions if there are any
let's see what we have here okay Flattr
of the mill conceptual area is the first
one that started it all good to me okay
good for you why is a flat plane the
only thing they can imagine is grab you
know and one of the things I one of the
things I always ask about the plane you
know the flat the word flat is how
flight is lat
and then over the five flat I mean you
know they're aware that there's
something called Mount Everest and this
when you raise that against them they
say well we know that it's not perfectly
flat then then how flat is flat I mean
the way I look at it I define flat first
first thought you have to define the
word flat and when I define flat as zero
thickness that's flat and obviously that
rules out Mount Everest and so they say
well that's not our definition well what
is your definition and so this is where
we have a problem because you know the
earth is not flat even under their
definition they have all these bumps on
the earth so it's not a pancake and then
even if it were a pinky how thick is the
pancake and how do you know I mean if
you look under the earth to find out how
thick that pancake is maybe it's
zero-dimensional and if it's zero
dimensional well you don't have much of
a pancake do you you have much of
nothing and so you get up defined the
word flat and these people never do okay
gravity is the reason used to be a flat
earther okay if you get round to win a
have you win when they have you thought
about how the robot they can explain
gyroscope rigidity behavior in the
phenomena we call inertia
nice work on that okay okay that's some
people hold to the idea that science is
the only study cause-effect
relationships well again we have to
define what science is and in a lot of
these people don't define in fact we
don't have a definition problem from the
establishment that's that's a serious
problem because if they had a definition
we could hold them to it but since they
have here this guy says its observation
there's other guys say that's experiment
the other guy says that it's prediction
you know so we have all these different
versions and and you say well you said
observation but you're talking about
prediction well yeah because for me it's
prediction you say oh the
experimentation in this guy says no it's
a I don't know is hypothesizing or
whatever so so we got a problem we need
a definition of
Sciences we need a definition what
physics is and then we'll find out if
all these guys are doing physics science
or whatever and essentially what these
people have done over the years at least
since the days of Newton is turn all all
of science essentially physics right
they turned it into experiments and math
in other words experiments in calculate
calculations and equations and they call
that science but all they've done is
description again if I do an experiment
and then I measure and say okay the the
acceleration of gravity is 9.8 meters
per second squared for example right
what have I learned I mean all I'm doing
is just giving you I measured and say
this is the the speed or the
acceleration do I get a Nobel for that I
mean it's like saying oh yeah I measured
how fast the lion nog runs or gallops
you know after the gazelle and it was I
don't know 30 miles per hour so I mean
you timed it in that science now science
explaining something otherwise you don't
use your brain just to measure out there
and give a equation or calculation
that's not science and that's where the
problem is
we don't have a definition of science
okay it pictures an object picture of
then see that okay where is it up and
down to the horizontal I guess as
follows referring to the the fact that
the electricity I guess you're referring
to the you know you have the vertical
electricity and then sideways what you
have is the threads so if if you have in
the north-south direction you have
electricity okay which is simply merge
cells they're all twirling so the whole
serpent thing is is turning like a
barber's pole right then to the side
what you're going to have is the
sweeping of the threads electromagnetic
threads they are sweeping around and
that's going to create the magnetic
field so the magnetic field under the
rope model has to go always
perpendicular to the flow of electricity
one goes this way and you can measure it
a top and bottom okay you see that it's
there's something there there's a
there's a potential as they call it and
then the threads that are moving around
that creates the field and that's going
perpendicular to that flow so
electricity always is perpendicular to
magnetism and wherever there's
electricity there's always magnetism you
can't separate the two and so you know
some people think they can okay well
I'll call it a day and we'll continue
next time with what will go with one of
the celebrities I've put off twice now
we'll see you that bye-bye